je suis charge incana garage je suis
chargé recrutement pour la société
safran aircraft and in pour le site de
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est à la recherche
d'environ dizaine de mécaniciens et
également des inspecteurs moteur
[Musique]
le mécanisme hauteur et est chargé de
démonter de moteurs et de dispatcher un
peu les modules et ensuite une fois que
c'est réparé et de remonter
le moteur dans un ensemble où le module
donc l'inspecteur c'est juste avant le
mécanisme moteur donc l'inspecteur il
fait donc une inspection générale du
moteur ou des modules donc c'est comme
un médecin généraliste qui regarde si le
produit va bien
[Musique]
vous êtes issu voilà d'une formation en
aéronautique que ce soit un bts ou bac
pro donc bien sûr c'est les profils
recherchés mais aujourd'hui voilà si
vous venez donc de l'automobile ou dans
notre domaine avec une expertise
mécanique vous êtes les bienvenus si
vous intéressé par le poste il suffit de
postuler sur le site de safran point com
et également nous suivre dans les
réseaux comme linkedin sutter instagram